o
Windows não sei E aí o perdão que eu
tava trabalhando aqui no projeto desde a
semana passada eu tô assim ó
o hospital dá para ver muito muito legal
deixa eu falar só que está esperando
aqui umas duas horas
esperando era outras pessoas que votaram
mas eu pensei porque a gente tava
esperando a galera para instalar uma
tirolesa aqui dentro
eu te falei que é uma coisa que a gente
gosta de realmente tratar o funcionário
como se fosse uma pessoa da família um
parente né não galera 8d
E é porque então lembra quando você for
divulgar o teu show a gente fez né
aquelas pessoas que eles estão usando de
área vip que não é mais a identificação
mesmo é porque pode conhecer de um tá no
Multishow o outro tá no Faustão começa
na internet o Twitter hashtag 2 o
Whindersson como é que tá E aí eu tenho
que ir trabalhar não é reprise não sei
que quando está próximo muito um do
outro ela vibra a gente fica sem
dinheiro a gente pode falar no programa
aqui que a gente acaba não futuro é
exposta nos fundos que é um Reality Show
para encontrar um novo integrante por
Porta dos Fundos vai estar no YouTube
até se um futuro é sempre uma
brincadeira para todo mundo que a gente
contrata não posso ver fica famoso
história isso nem todo mundo se tem
gente que é fiel que tá ali
de fidelidade aí não que eu contratei um
rapaz de lá semana passada ele vai
reclamando da questão de
quente isso meu irmão
se isso aqui não é melhor na vida é um
doido é
o pessoal começa estão contratando
Espera aí é brincadeira dela aqui pra
caramba Vem cá você tá com tatuagem na
cara nunca reclamar é que eu tô feliz
aqui então
aqui a gente ajuda o funcionário aí
atrás do sonho de se sabia que o
que é isso é carinho muito especial de
Natal Agora
é
só você saber
2012 que não vamos falar nada divulgação
eu tenho uma pessoa para falar com você
viu seu Antônio que eu
queria conversar e
é super fácil empreender mesmo ela te
prender não é nada para me levar para
festa aqui é o convite não vai com que
não vale o que
ajuda a reconhecer eu te falar uma coisa
então não dá uma laçada né se não
aguento eu vou te pedir que não não
porque você não quer divulgar a série de
vocês não rapaz
e me alérgico a coentro Só avisa o moço
e
e como é que faz para ver esse negócio
de vocês aí você fala aí tem que botar
no YouTube Originals seu carro e como é
que acesse
não sei mexer nesse tecnologia
Ah mas daqui a um menino Ela é 10 Então
manda botar no 10 falar para ele sair
programando lá que eu chegar em casa eu
vejo tá por aí é levar até aquele não é
E aí ai ai
[Música]
foram mais de 7 mil inscritos para
participarem do reality show do Porta
dos Fundos de hoje chegou o dia de
escolher os 10 finalistas vão escolher
aleatóriamente qualquer idiota que eles
comprar na rua aqui onde fez com
Portugal Deus é porque a sua humilhação
e
isso é surreal daquele tarde eu sou até
agora se eu ficar uma pegadinha eu acho
mais semana de prova acha que vai ter
doação a nossa cara é igual a Hora da
Verdade esposa boa tarde boa noite tá
aqui no riacho pra gente ter um futuro a
exporta foi o ramo de tal e qual o seu
talento irmão isso tudo é mentira tá
pode
[Música]
e eu quero meu Roberto você que tá
acontecendo ainda é
e é a chegado o momento de eliminar
alguém nesse reality difícil né gente
nada que prepara para isso
tá tendo não pode demonstrar já Olha a